bienvenue dans ta nouvelle maison notre
nouvelle maison
[Musique]
sera prise
les enfants ils chantent que nous ayons
survécu à une énorme perturbation de
conducteur mais qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé au juste derrière
arrêtez de vous battre
y est j'ai fini
un nouveau virus est en train de se
répandre
qui permet de savoir combien on
s'enfonce que ton fils géant dans le nez
ça a l'air trop marrant je vais faire ça
une centaine de fois par jour
il y a pas mal dehors la loi au pays de
la crypto
[Musique]
pourquoi t'as pas les fesses lui
rebondit désolé les gars j'ai le cul
plein
[Musique]
et mon cul c'est du téflon
ok je l'ai mérité
je suis content de te retrouver
non s'il te plaît vraiment oui bien sûr
non je voulais dire c'est trop glauque
[Musique]